in this lesson we're going to talk about
parabolas and quadratics and the
different forms that they can be written
in whether its vertex form intercept
form or just the general form and this
is an important concept you want to
understand for the svt so let's jump
right into it let's talk about the three
different forms so first of all you've
got this general form let's just
multiply it out it's in descending order
and you've got your coefficients a B and
C in front of the variables right so the
way you would find the vertex which is
the point where the parabola bends or
turns if you use this formula x equals
negative B over 2a so the opposite of b
over 2 times the leading coefficient so
for this example here i would do the
opposite of b which is negative 4 over 2
times a which is 2 and so negative 4
over 4 gives us negative 1 now if I put
negative 1 back into my equation for x I
get 2 times negative 1 squared is 2 plus
4 times negative 1 is negative 4 plus
one that comes out to negative 1 so the
vertex here is going to be at negative 1
negative 1 the axis of symmetry goes
right through that x coordinate of
vertex the a value is positive which
tells us that it's opening up like this
and so that's a quick sketch of the
graph right there this one is in vertex
form okay and you can see the vertex is
going to be at each k and then a is the
vertical stretch if it's positive it's
going to open up if it's negative it's
going to open down so for this one we
can see that the vertex is at positive 3
positive 1 and notice that this one is
group of the ax has the opposite sign
the opposite effects is actually
positive 3 it goes x + 3 then it would
be shifting last three okay and then
what the a value does since this
negative it's going to open down and the
three is going to stretch it which means
is going to be mere or can we go down
faster so this graph is going to look
something like this approximately and
then the last one this is what's called
intercept form you can also think of it
as like a factored form okay it's
factored and by setting the factor these
groups equal to zero you can solve for
the x-intercepts what we set this to 0
we get to we set this to 0 we get four
and what you want to do is find a
halfway point between those two
x-intercepts and that's going to be your
line of symmetry it's also going to be
the x coordinate of your vertex so in
this case that's x equals 3 by putting
free back into
you are equations we can solve for the y
coordinate of the vertex so let's do
that 3-2 is 13 minus 4 is negative 1 and
x a half if we multiply that all out we
get y equals negative one-half so this
is going to be at three negative half
right there and then you can see there's
our parabola like soul so these are the
three forms that you want to memorize
and familiarize yourself for for the s80
so let's go to some examples go ahead
and pause the video so you can do these
on your own to give us this equation and
it says which of the following is an
equivalent form of the equation of the
graph in the XY plane from which the
intercepts can be identified as
constants in the equation so they're
telling us they want us to put it into
intercept form that's this form right
over here this third one well you can
see the first one is in vertex form okay
that's this form right here this was
like in a general form it can't be that
one this one I'm not even sure what form
this is in it has to be letter C but I
would verify it by doing a couple things
you know one you can foil this out we
multiply it out and you can see that yes
it does match this one here so all it is
is this is the factored form of this and
you can see that X intercepts are going
to be at negative 3 positive 1 you can
find a halfway point that's your axis of
symmetry which is negative 1 and by
putting negative 1 back in you can find
the y coordinate and draw your parabola
okay example 2 it says the equation y
equals x squared minus 6x plus 8
represents the parabola which of the
following displays the vertex as
constants in the equation okay so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
do this one to give us a few options you
know and which one do you think it would
be well the first of all this first one
looks like it's in the intercept form
see how it's the fashion forum so that's
not it this one looks like it's in the
vertex form this one I'm not sure where
formas even represents and this one and
again I'm not sure what that even
represent so it looks like it's letter B
but I would confirm by doing a couple
different things one you could go ahead
and you could factor this you could say
this is X minus 4x minus 2 okay so what
I've done is I've written in the
intercept form and you could graph it
you can see it's going to cross that
positive tube you set this to 0 and
positive 4 piece of that 20 you find
that halfway point that's your axis of
symmetry
x equals 3 and by putting it back in you
get negative 1 and positive one so if
you multiply those together you get
negative 1 so you can see your vertex is
going to be right here at three comma
negative one like so so your problems
going to look like that so if we use the
vertex form you can see it's going to be
y equals a X minus 3 squared minus 1
right so it looks like this is in that
correct form you can see the vertex is
at 3 negative 1 so letter B is going to
be your best answer there so go ahead
and review these three forms of the
parabola definitely something you want
to know for the SKT and if you have to
review these examples go ahead and do
that as well I'll see you in the next
lesson